Transcriber: Burak Yildiz
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Biliyorsunuz ki konumuz yapay zekânın
birey ve toplum üzerine etkisi.
Şunu söylemem gerekiyor ki,
yapay zekâ uygulama alanı
her geçen gün daha da gelişerek
modern hayatımızın bir parçası oluyor
ve ben de bugün sizlere
yapay zekânın sosyal medya
ve eğitsel uygulama
alanlarından bahsedeceğim.
Ama öncelikle sizlere yapay zekâyı
kısaca tanımlamak istiyorum.
İngilizce olarak
″Artificial Intelligence″
″AI″ diye bildiğimiz yapay zekâ,
kimilerine göre
insanlığın sonunu getirebilecek
işsizliği ortaya çıkarabilecek
bir tehdit olarak görülüyorken,
kimilerine göre ise
hayatımızı kolaylaştıracak,
geleceğin mesleklerini ortaya
çıkarabilecek bir fırsat olarak görülüyor.
Düşünelim.
Bundan 10 yıl önce,
sosyal medya uzmanları,
e-ticaret uzmanları veya veri mühendisleri
var mıydı?
Benim asıl bahsetmek istediğim konu,
sosyal medyada e-ticaret.
E-ticaret, elektronik ticaret,
ürünlerin internet üzerinden alınması
ve satılması işlemidir.
Bana sosyal medyayı, e-ticareti,
yapay zekâyı birbirlerine
nasıl bağladığını
soracak olursanız, şöyle ki;
e-ticarete sosyal medyaya yön verir.
Sosyal medya ise bir yapay zekâ üretir.
Aslında yapay zekânın
temel amaçlardan biri de,
e-ticareti sağlamaktır.
İşte bunu da sosyal medya sayesinde yapar.
Peki yapay zekâ, bilim ile toplumu
e-ticaretle birlikte nasıl etkileyecek?
Her konuda olduğu gibi,
tabii ki bu konunun da bizlere sağladığı
avantajlar ve dezavantajlar var.
Şimdi size biraz bunlardan
bahsedeceğim.
Avantajlarından başlayacak olursak.
Yapay zekâ sayesinde hem hayatımız
küçümsenemeyecek kadar çok kolaylaşıyor
hem de şu hayattaki en değerli şeyimiz
olan zamanımızın tasarrufunu sağlıyor.
Bununla da bitmiyor.
Yapay zekâ, e-ticaret ile birlikte
mesafeleri hükmetmekle kalmayıp
onu ortadan kaldırıyordu.
Burada akıllara
″E-ticaret ne kadar güvenlidir?″
sorusu da gelebiliyor.
Şöyle ki, yolda yürümek
ne kadar güvenliyse
e-ticaret de işte o kadar güvenlidir.
Art niyetli kişiler olduktan sonra,
birileri muhakkak açıklar bulabilecek
ve bilgilerinize ulaşabilecektir.
Biraz önce yapay zekânın bizlere zaman
tasarrufu sağladığını söylemiştim.
Bunu yapay zekâ nasıl yapıyor olabilir?
Yapay zekâ, sosyal medyamızdan
topladığı verilerle e-ticaret sayfalarını
bizler için kişiselleştiriyor.
Sosyal medyamızda,
neyi sevip sevmediğinizi,
neye ilgi duyup duymadığınızı ve
taramalarımızdan, etkileşimlerimizden
verilerini alıyor; sosyal medyamızı
bize göre uyarlıyor.
Hiç düşündünüz mü?
Bu uygulamalar, Instagram,
Twitter, Facebook
neden ücretli değil?
Aslında cevap çok basit.
Bir şey ücretsizse,
oradaki ürün sizsinizdir.
Bu uygulamalar e-ticaret için
veri topluyorlar ve bizlere
bazı avantajlar sağlıyorlar.
Örneğin, alışveriş yapmak için
bir mağazaya girdiğinizde,
herkes için sunulan
belirli seçeneklerle karşılaşıyoruz.
O seçenekler arasından kendi istediğinize,
zevkinize uygun olana,
buranın altını çizerek söylemek istiyorum.
Zamanınızı ayırarak bulmamız gerekiyor.
Oysa ki kendi e-ticaret sayfamıza
girdiğinizde bizim için kişiselleşmiş
bir ekran bizi karşılıyor.
Kolayca filtrele diyerek,
istediğimiz ürünün bedenini, rengini,
markasını, çeşidini ve böyle pek çok
seçeneği kolayca aratarak bulabiliyoruz.
Hatta şöyle bildirimler de alıyoruz
e-ticaret sayfalarımızdan:
Baktığınız ürün indirime girdi.
Oysa ki bunun olmadığını düşünürsek,
bence hem zamanımızdan
tasarruf etmemiş olurduk
hem de zaman kaybetmiş olurduk.
Ama unutmayalım ki,
e-ticaret sayfaları da tabi ki bunları
kendi çıkarlarını
düşündükleri için yapıyorlar.
Eminim, hepimiz bu soruyu da sormuşuzdur:
Google bizi dinliyor mu?
Evet dinliyor çünkü size göre içerikler
çıkarması gerekiyor.
Zaten sosyal medya medyanızı açtığınızda,
sizin ilgi alanlarınızda sizin
hoşunuza giden şeyler çıkıyor.
Örneğin, internetten bir ayakkabı
baktınız ya da arattınız.
Bu işlemlerden hemen sonrası,
slaytta da gördüğünüz gibi
ekranınızın yanlarına hemen
ayakkabı reklamları çıkmaya başlıyor.
Yani yapay zekâ,
e-ticaretin sizin için daha kullanışlı,
erişebilir ve verimli hâle getirmek için
sosyal medyanızı sizler için
kişiselleştiriyor.
Rutin görevlilerimiz ve sorumluklarımız
oldukça meşgulken,
en azından banka işlemlerimizi veya
kişisel ihtiyaçlarımızı burada line etmek,
konfor alanımızda kalmamızı sağlıyor.
Zaten yapay zekânın
temel amaçlarından biri de,
insana konfor alanı sağlamaktır.
Bu konuyla ilgili
bir dezavantajdan da bahsetmek istiyorum.
Sosyal medyamızı açtığımızda,
bizimle aynı görüşte olan,
bizimle aynı şeyi savunan kişileri
izliyor ve dinliyoruz.
Hatta bu konuyla alakalı,
Akan Abdula’da ″Öngörülemeyenler″
adlı kitabında bir kavramdan bahsediyor:
Yankı Odaları.
Şöyle ki, sosyal medya en çok etkileşime
geçtiğiniz beş kişiyi referans alarak,
sizler için ortak içerikler üretiyor.
Ardından da bu içerikleri sizlere sunuyor.
Dolayısıyla sizin karşınıza
sizinle zıt düşünen kişiler çıkmıyor,
videoları veya yazıları çıkmıyor.
Böylelikle aslında, fark etmeden
farklı fikirlere karşı kapanıyoruz
ve bizimle zıt düşünen
kişiyi hoş görmedik.
Hızlı bir şekilde yargılaya başlıyoruz.
Şimdi farklı bir soru sormak istiyorum.
Yapay zekâ ilerledikçe,
teknoloji ilerledikçe
e-ticaret sizce bu durumdan
nasıl etkilenecek?
Mesela son zamanlarda çıkan e-ticaret
girişimlerinden haberiniz var mı?
Ben sizler için bir e-ticaret
girişim örneği verebilirim.
Londra merkezli
ve e-ticaret girişimi olan Metail,
bizlere kıyafetleri
dijital ortamda deneme fırsatı sunuyor.
Şimdi Metail ile ilgili
kısacık bir video izletmek istiyorum.
Ardından da devam edeceğim sunumuma.
Metail, sağladığı teknolojik avantajla,
e-ticaret sayfalarının
satışlarını arttırıyor.
E-ticaretin toplam perakende içerisindeki
payını artırırken, burası çok önemli,
ürün deneme bariyerini
aşınmasına katkı sağlıyor.
Üç boyutlu vücut örneği
çıkarılan kullanıcılar,
kıyafetleri mağazaya gitmeden
kısa sürede deneme şansı buluyor.
Metail kurucusu Tom Adeyoola,
%95 kestirimle
başarılı bir model sunduklarını,
8 bin parça giyim eşyasını
dijital ortama taşıdıklarını söylüyor.
Yani konuyu toparlayacak olursam;
yapay zekâ, e-ticaret ve
sosyal medya ile birlikte,
bizlere büyük bir konfor, zaman tasarrufu
ve mekân bağımsızlığı sağlıyor.
En son sunumumu şu sözlerle
bitirmek istiyorum.
Yapay zekâ her yerde,
gelecekteki o kadar büyük,
korkunç bir şey değil.
Yapay zekâ burada bizimle.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)